David is with us in San Antonio hi David
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hello mr. Ramsey how are you this
afternoon better than I deserve sir how
are you
I am well but I am at a crossroads okay
uh because of losing a very good job a
messy divorce
oh man and a lot of legal fees on my
part because of losing the job I and the
expenses I have from the divorce I know
I've read your book and I know how you
feel about bankruptcy but I'm almost to
the point where I don't see any other
alternative I'm currently working three
jobs to pay my child support their
insurance and my percent my next ten
years of the mortgage payment which
leaves me very little for myself and I
have about eighty five thousand dollars
in personal debt from legal fees and
other things so you doing Adam
no I'm the company did something very
unethical I lost my security clearance
and my professional engineering license
so no one will hire me as an engineer
and so you lost the lawsuit yes after
spending all that money yes sir why
because I tried to clear my name because
I personally wasn't involved directly in
that project but they slapped it the
government's left everybody very hard
Wow huh is that a permanent situation
the loss of your uh my security clones
probably unless I can get them to reopen
the investigation and right now my
problem is I paid $1,200 a month in
child support I have three very young
children we started late I have to pay
nine hundred fifty dollars on the
mortgage for ten years and then I'm
required to pay their insurance which
I'm going without insurance but
maintaining their insurer well that's as
it should be um if you have to choose
you take care of the kids oh yeah of
course
and that's why the the my your paying
the mortgage on the house she's living
in yes and that's your divorce
settlement uh yes I have to pay ten
years worth of the mortgage and she got
half my 401k
a-and I spent the other half on legal
fees man you your choice of lawyers has
not been good you know who lost on both
of these didn't you yes sir got your
tail kicked huh eighty-five thousand
dollars in legal fees and then some
personal debt but very most of its legal
fees okay what do you mean you're
working three jobs just odd job just to
try to keep these bills pay I'm working
as a draftsman because they'll allow me
to do that and that pays about $13 an
hour i work as a server and then at the
cook at a restaurant like i worked my
way through college how many years ago
how old are you I'm 45 all right when
did you lose this job uh in December of
last year so a year and a half ago what
about the divorce
about a year ago Wow so these are all
tied up together then yes and I look at
this is God giving me a message that
this is your chance to start over but
I'm not sure where to go from here yeah
because I'm not gonna sacrifice my child
support I sold my car I ride a bicycle
to work at my age because I'm going to
take care of my children
yeah I appreciate that you are that guy
um well a bankruptcy gets rid of the
legal fees obviously it does not get rid
of any the child support or the the no
and I wouldn't have it any I wouldn't
have anyway with that and um it does get
rid of the personal debt but really
you're not paying on either one of those
things right now are you uh very I'm
trying to pay $50 here $25 here just to
keep up good faith and show them that I
because I look at it is a personal
feeling on my part that I can't pay my
bills yeah well I appreciate that but
it's it's a series of events that got
you here I mean I don't know that
bankruptcy increases your it doesn't
increase your cash flow today because
really you're not spending much on the
things that are going to be bankrupted
do you follow me yes sir I do if the one
of them sues you and starts taking some
of this precious income then you may be
forced into bankruptcy but for today as
long as they'll sit on the sidelines and
stay away from you for a little while
and give
time to get back on your feet then maybe
they get paid but if you're having to
pay payments on all of that then that's
a different thing or if they're one of
them are suing you then that's a
different thing it may force you into
bankruptcy but right now what it more
than anything you just had the crap beat
out of you I would say so but are you
are you an an backup
yeah are you in a good Church yes sir I
am good that's the one thing that's
divorced it to me as my wife wasn't very
religious and I got away from for my
faith but we're back now yeah that's
good oh you gotta take a break I
appreciate you talking to me to listen
it's good to talk to you call back if I
can help anyway I would put I would tap
the brakes on the bankruptcy because I
don't see it accomplishes anything today
and I just keep fighting and you got it
you got a handful right there
you